Cái mình tạm hả sau tại Hanoi.
Vậy nguồn và giáo dục Việt Nam, với đàn sân, sử dư sân và nâng,
tổ chí khổi khảo không ngố phía khoảng những thứ về thực trạng và giải pháp thuốc đầy
sự tham gia khẩy thao của trẻ gái các trung học thực dở tại Việt Nam.
Cổ thảo được tổ chức tại thành phố Hanoi.
Theo những thực thực tiếp, các thực thực tuyến có sự tham dự thực tiếp của khoảng tạm
với đại biểu.
Lắc các nhà quan lý đến từ bộ nó giúp gà nào tạo.
Cục thay dục kia thao Việt Nam, khi đại diễn từ các tổ chức tổ lỡ như UNESCO,
các quan lý hục quốc về mình nhận giới và cho quyền cho phùn hữu.
Y me sẹp và quyết dần số lý hục quốc.
Bên cạnh đó, sự góc mặt của lãnh đạo các sử dấu giục và đạo thạo
từ cân thơ, quế, ring ring, cung cắt chân ra, giáo viên thị chất
và các nước bản động viên có tạm mạnh hưởng.
Các sử dấu và đạo thảo chình tòan quốc với 3 mi tư đều cầu.
Đã tạo nên một dễ đàn đại chiều xấu xác về câu chuyển thể thảo học đường cho chả em gái.
Cái qua khá sách trực chuyến trên hơn 3 chăm 2 tư, bình đối thửa tại 3 mi tư tình thành phố cho thấy.
Dì lệ học sinh lưỡi tham ra vận đầu, bình tập học chơi thể thang ngoài dơ đạn 5.5 mả mi só phân chăm.
Thấp hơn 6.5 gần mi táng điểm phân chăm, xí có 2 mi phải tham phân chăm học sinh lưỡi chỉ mức vận động
biểu một dơ mũ ngài trường lên.
Nguyên cứu cũng chỉ ra nhiều rau cả như thiếu một thế thảo phù hợp.
Dơ học còn đơn đều tâm đi thiếu tự tin, sợ bị chế cười, lòng ngại trấn thương và ablực khi thăm ra các khóa động thiếu thảo.
Bộ sợi bộ sô có bộ cho các bạn được.
Nguyên này theo các khí bộ nghiệp kiểu chúng tôi đã trình khai thì cái tỷ lệ mọc sinh lưỡi só bởi sinh nàn
thăm ra vận động.
Dơ chuyện với kể trên thay đường mặt khảo sát, bể các kể sử dụng thích cho hay là khải sử dụng bọc sinh trong cái mua
thì hầu giữ tất cả chí số, học sinh lưỡi tất cả hình xa đọc trong hỏng hà hình chăm các chí số
thử kể thay đột ít tất, đến kể hành vi thăm ra vải, đến kể bất đột vận động của liên là cái thử lực của nó các bạn phải có.
Điều thấp hình học sinh nàn và kể dụng tố ở đây thì nó đến với chiều tố.
Nó là dụng tố xó bắt đến bộ tại của học sinh nưỡi sợ các kể dụng tố mua chường xung phai tất lợc.
Ví dụng như là mặt để ra đi, ra chứ.
Số dụng tố bị chạm địa kiện cho trong xa hội nữa.
Còn có những tất lợng chức tiếp đến các đăng của nó đến kể kể kể biệt ngã sinh hòa.
Hãy nhìn thấy về đồng hộ hạn này ngọt.
Tâm sông với hoạt động như cứu, dụng an đã trình khai các hoá tập vũn cho gáo viên và tổ chức ngày hội thịt thào tại nhiều trường học ở ninh bình,
thành phố hối và cân thơ.
Cái khoảng bức đầu cho thấy, khi các hoạt động được thiết kể theo dưỡng thân thiện,
đa dạng và dạm áp lực thành tích.
Hau sinh lửa thăm ra thiết cơ hơn, các chuyên gia kì vọng những thiết khoảng nguyên cứu và mù hình thực hiện,
sẽ có phần xây dựng mùi chương thịt thào học đường an toàn hoàn nhập.
Tào đu kiện để chế em gái phát triển bằng dựng cả về thiết lẫn thiết thân.